[Música]
hay datos sobre las perspectivas
económicas del fondo
monetariointernacional los detalles los
tiene mi compañero jorge hurtado quien
ya me acompaña que en el estudio muy
buenas noches jorge que dijeron qué
cifras hay cuál es la perspectiva en
general hay un panorama bastante sombrío
para la economía global el fm calcula
que ahora la economía mundial crecerá
sólo un 3,2 por ciento este año y un 2,9
por ciento el año que viene el organismo
afirma que los tres motores económicos
del mundo que son eeuu china y la zona
euro se están frenando y eso genera ya
importantes consecuencias para la
economía global entre las causas alta
inflación ralentización más larga y
pronunciada de lo esperado de la
economía china y los efectos negativos
sobre todo de la guerra en ucrania
respecto a eeuu el organismo no prevé
que caiga en recesión este año y el que
viene aunque dijeron que un pequeño
shock podría ser suficiente para
llevarlo a ese escenario escuchemos
es un camino muy estrecho el entorno
actual sugiere que la probabilidad de
que la economía estadounidense puede
evitar una recesión es en realidad
bastante estrecha según nuestras
proyecciones actuales por ejemplo para
eeuu la tasa de crecimiento trimestral
en 2023 es sólo del 0.6 por ciento y un
0.6 por ciento eso es bajo nuestra línea
de base por lo tanto un pequeño choque
en este punto podría ser suficiente para
que la economía de los eeuu se desprenda
de una cifra bastante baja y se incline
hacia una recesión seria y que dijeron
jorge de américa latina' de nuestra
región y del caribe de hecho es una de
las pocas regiones del mundo que mostró
una perspectiva en positivo la robusta
recuperación de sus principales
economías hizo que el fondo monetario
internacional aumentara sus previsiones
de crecimiento para la región hasta el
3% de este año eso es medio punto más
que su anterior estimación aunque para
el año 2023 la economía en latinoamérica
y el caribe crecerá medio punto menos de
lo previsto con sus dos principales
economías que son méxico y brasil
registrando cifras inferiores a este
esto sería porque la región tiene menos
vínculos directos con europa pero sería
más afectada por la inflación y el
endurecimiento de las políticas
monetarias
cambiamos de tema y frente al temor del
suministro de gas ruso para europa el
bloque comunitario ya empieza a tomar
medidas tratamos este tema en la parte
de noticias vamos a profundizar acá
bueno lo que quieren es reducir la
demanda de gas en un 15 por ciento desde
el mes de agosto hasta marzo del próximo
año la medida plantea acciones
voluntarias para reducir el consumo de
gas pero si no se consigue un ahorro
suficiente se activarían acciones
obligatorias en el bloque de los 27
miembros los ministros de energía
firmaron el compromiso justo un día
después de que la rusa gazprom dijera
que iba a reducir el flujo de gas de
alemania el 20 por ciento de su
capacidad a partir de este miércoles
desde la guerra en ucrania ya hay 12
países de la unión europea que se han
visto obligados a interrumpir o reducir
sus suministros de gas ruso el
suministro ruso pasó del 40 por ciento
al 15 por ciento lo que ha disparado los
precios y pone en apuros a la industria
que consumen sobre todo mucha energía
precisamente en ese contexto eeuu se
convirtió en el primer exportador de gm
l gas natural licuado en el mundo esto
en el primer semestre de este año eeuu
ya va en camino de superar el compromiso
de joe biden de destinar 15 mil millones
de metros cúbicos adicionales de gas a
europa este año según un análisis de la
agencia reuters esto es una buena
noticia para el presidente baile que ha
tratado de reforzar los lazos
energéticos con europa como forma de
combatir la influencia de rusia pero
dada la gran demanda de gas natural en
el mundo estas importaciones europeas se
producen a expensas de naciones más
pobres como pakistán o india que podrían
enfrentarse a déficit energético o
terminar negociando precisamente al gas
con rusia hasta junio de este año eeuu
exportó unos 57 mil millones de metros
cúbicos de gas de los cuales el 68 por
ciento tuvo como destino europa eeuu ya
enviado más gas a europa durante los
primeros seis meses de 2022 que en todos
los 12 meses de 2021 cambiamos de tema
hablemos ahora de la gigante minorista
wal mart que recortó su previsión de
ganancias para este año que les pasó y
bueno presionado por la subida de los
precios en ese país la inflación que
está haciendo que los consumidores
estadounidenses modifiquen sus hábitos
de consumo y como consecuencia las
ganancias de la empresa caerían hasta un
13% este año una situación similar
enfrenta target que acumula en
inventario en productos que nadie quiere
comprar porque los consumidores están
progresando por supuesto los alimentos
las acciones de wal mart cayeron hasta
un 9 por ciento en la bolsa tras esta
noticia
jorge muchas gracias por esta
actualización de las noticias de
economía es todo por el momento aquí en
directo américa en términos económicos
hablamos ahora en el debate
[Música]